the last thing that's on this table is
this one if you have a good memory if
you have a good memory you'll think back
to 24 house ago and this was where I
finished the lesson actually just look
at the phrase what does it mean it means
your repayment is exactly equal to the
interest that you're being charged so
what's happening to your balance the
balance that is owing still it just
states exactly the same as when you
started the interest gets charged your
repayment goes in it's just back and
forth and it's exactly equal okay um can
you remind me why would someone in their
right mind do that why in in 95% of
cases what you are doing is you are
using this loan to either buy property
or start a business venture that you
hope will in the end be more valuable
than when it started so you can sell
that off it will cover your original
debt and then you have a tidy sum on the
side that you have does that make sense
so yeah
so here's exactly how it looks maybe you
want to jot this down to help you
remember right under interest-only
payments the first thing you will say is
the most receipt way is just to say
repayments equal interest usually your
payments have to be more than your
interest so you keep on making little
dents in the balance that's owing okay
but interest OBPA means they're exactly
the same now let's just do a quick
example underneath okay as an example
let's suppose this year 2016
okay you buy a property right and it
costs let's say we don't buy in Sydney
so it's $250,000 or you or maybe you
bought like a cargo box in Sydney right
you bought your cardboard box you
borrowed that amount and then you are
you know time passes right you your
payments exactly balance out with the
interest is being charged okay so you
now oh sorry let's put a year
let's go 25 years in the future was that
2041 okay in 2041 you still owe that
same amount now you still over that
amounts in the bank but now the value of
your house maybe is higher if your
cardboard box the property that you've
got let's just say let's just say it
triples you know what in 25 years you
probably do more than that okay yeah
that's right
it's like guys this is a luxury cargo
box okay it's right it's free air
conditioning now the value of the house
has increased the value of the house
increased so you repay the loan the loan
was $250,000 right so in the net gain
what you gain is that $500,000
difference
okay now we'll point out just as a
practical thing you can't just do this
the bank the government will try to do
something called stamp duty and which if
you remember from buying cars is yes
it's a significant proportion so you're
not going to get that exact amount in
profit but you will make a profit
okay just well the bank is happy because
this whole time you are paying them like
repayment right you're making repayments
to them now it's not as big as if you
had we're actually paying off the loan
but you're giving them a steady stream
of income 1888 dollars every month for
well what they're doing is this
surrendering this big sum of money in
return for you
constantly sort of feeding them back
over a long period of time well they'll
have they'll have this and they'll have
it along with other things like their
they basically want to keep your
business and if they're your if they are
allowing you to do this chances are
you're gonna bake with them for other
stuff as well which they will make more
money off right it's the whole principle
of like yeah get your mobile.phone
Adrian's in it and your landline Angela
cable TV or from me cuz then I can make
more money off you does that make sense
there's one more thing I want to put on
here you should add this down the bottom
it's a really read it might be the most
important thing well no that's
exaggerating but it is very important
it's called an offset account okay an
offset account
okay here's the way it goes okay that's
all shortage ah that's very different
I'm very different okay um here's the
definition of an offset account
okay so I'll lay it out for you as
simply as I can and then you can tell me
why it's useful okay this is called a um
this is a transaction account that I'll
give you the phrase and then I'll
explain it
okay so let me explain this because this
is super important and if you get a
mortgage like an offset it comes with
obviously so let's picture this okay
you'd have bought a house and you're
like okay we make all this money now
okay and your income is coming to you to
your mania and every month you'll be
paying off every month as some of money
goes into your mortgage okay and there
disappears forever it's gone
the bank has that now if their money
after all okay so that's what's
happening in in your mortgage right but
then on the side like your income right
and your groceries and all that kind of
thing they come out of what's called
your transaction account because it's
the account which surprise surprise as
all the transactional money coming in
money going up it's the one that's
changing all the time right day to day
as soon as you don't tap on on like
public transport your open card says oh
you're out you're out of credit you need
to put some more on that transaction
happens to like think of it like
basically like your wallet right the
amount of money here is changing
constantly okay this is not your
mortgage you pay a mortgage out of this
but this is like the thing I can hold
this isn't thing I can do now your
trades actually can right it's got all
this money sitting in it but actually
you could put into your mortgage right
so what they do is they say if you've
got an offset account we treat all of
the money in your transaction account as
if it had paid off your mortgage think
about that for a second okay they
suppose you've got in your transaction
account maybe you've got like ten
thousand dollars that's not a huge
amount of money it's kind of like if I'm
in a car crashes like I need tomato
emergency repairs okay but it's enough
that it makes a difference the amount of
interest that you're learning okay so in
your transaction account you've got this
$10,000 sitting over here okay and you
still owe the bank this amount right
suppose you haven't made any repayments
yet if you are able to if your bank will
let you treat this as an offset account
then they won't charge you interest as
are you 250 does not charge you interest
as if you are 240,000 okay that means
any money that's sitting in your wallet
in your transaction account it's working
for you it's reducing this which is
really important as we demonstrated the
smaller this is a small me interest they
actually get off okay now offset account
it dramatically reduces the amount of
interest that you're paying off okay so
that's why it's such an important
feature it's often expensive you have to
pay for fee for it but it's worth it
because of the effect it has for example
just like at the moment I'll give you
the exact numbers but my offset account
right now is about hmm I think it's
about half the size it's about hot stock
in this scheme if I go two hundred fifty
thousand dollars no thanks Kerry if I
over two hundred fifty thousand dollars
in a be as if whoops sorry you didn't
see it it's as if they're not going to
charge me interest on 250 doesn't know
they're gonna charge me interest on half
of that that's a really big deal isn't
it right that's like thousands of
dollars every month tens of thousands
every year okay so it makes a big
difference which is why we need together
don't know what but I'm not any interest
but I'm reducing the interest that's
getting charged to me okay
and that's actually better that's
actually better right because you might
think of it like this imagine this okay
you might think a borrow money and then
I just put in a bank account and then
it's very interest while they just use
that interest to pay off the interest of
their charge in minutes and the reason
why is because the interest they charge
you will always be more than the
interest you get back the banks are
trying to make money how to do this is
the way they'll arrange it okay so
therefore it's so much better for me to
have my money sitting here reduce the
amount of interest it's to in charge to
me rather than having it sit in some
savings account getting me interest
that's less than this anyway it's always
the disability won't call good debt and
bad debt right good debt like it's okay
to have death so what as it's low
interest in total right so you're hexed
you might talk perhaps yesterday right
hex debt is really good death they're
not really charging you interest on it
they're just charging you inflation
right so you can actually leave your
heck step there don't pay it live as
long as possible because your bank
account is making more money then your
hex Ted is taking away from okay so
that's why most people only pay off
their head step because it gets like the
government takes out a you do have a
choice you know how we've just been
saying all right hey this numbers really
important this that was really important
this is the one you do all the
calculations on right but then it's like
oh hey look at all this other stuff that
that is and this is complicated isn't it
right so the government has said you
know what like I said to all the banks
you're trying to confuse people and
people are getting ripped off because
they are confused so by law by law and
the page will come up there is something
called a comparison rate okay
I just just read this with me it's worth
the 30 seconds okay a comparison rate is
basically that first percentage and then
they add on as a percentage all the
other stuff that's in the fine print to
give you an estimate it's not it's not a
replacement for
getting into the nuts and bolts and
looking at other numbers in fine detail
but when you come and have a look down
here right it's like yeah you want to
borrow this about this is the interest
rate will charge you oh by the way tiny
fine print nice things you'll have to do
this there's conditions etc so there are
actually additional things you're going
to have to pay in addition to this basic
number so that number you get to compare
between loans because that's what these
are about
is called the comparison or you see how
tire yeah that's fine so it's like this
one plus all these additional fees and
charges that come into it and you really
need to worry about those as well
because obviously that make a difference